Speaker 1: Let's go next to Dev from
Syracuse, New York. Dev, welcome to The
David Pakman Show. What's on your mind today?
Speaker 2: Hi, David. I've got a question for
you. Sure. Can you hear me All right?
Speaker 1: I can hear you fine.
Speaker 2: All right. Well, Syracuse, I don't
know if you know much about Syracuse, upstate New
York. It is a pretty mixed place, but probably
a little more leaning to the right in general.
Lots of suburbs and and country farm areas.
So I would describe myself as a progressive,
independent. And I know titles are a difficult
thing, but I recently became a firearm owner.
Okay. And I was wondering. What your opinion is
on personal firearm use in the context of a tool
that might be used for some things in the future.
I kind of look at it like an EpiPen, right? It's
something that I never want to use. I'm not really
a hunter, but I want to have it available in a
situation that may occur where it would be useful.
Speaker 1: Well, listen, you bring up a really
interesting point. And I've had a I have a lot
of friends who are progressive gun owners, many,
many, many friends. I've opted never to talk on
the show about whether or not I own firearms.
Like, I've made it clear I support certain
rules and I've said we have a Second Amendment,
but we have to do something about the gun
like people know. But I've sort of like
stopped short of saying exactly like what
I do or don't have just because it doesn't
there doesn't seem to be any advantage to that.
And if I said exactly what I do or don't have,
I just don't know if there's any win
there. But one thing that is very, very
compelling to me is any scenario
that is a hypothetical scenario
that comes up in which the right wingers have
all or most of the guns, That doesn't sound good,
even if I think we are much better off reducing
the number of firearms out there by 95%.
And like, for example, even if we could limit them
to people who demonstrate that they're for hunting
use or it's for target shooting and you keep it
at the range in a safe that's there, or if you can
demonstrate an actual need for self-defense,
not the vague I've got to go like, okay,
maybe that would be the the ideal thing. Reduce
the number of guns out there by 95%. We don't have
that situation. And therefore, I don't really love
the idea of the right wingers having all the guns
and what you're talking about. These contingency
scenarios make a lot of sense to me in terms of a
motivation to say I want to own some firearms.
Speaker 2: You know, New York is I don't know
all of the gun laws across the country, but
it seems like New York is one of the most
strict gun laws areas in any of the states. And
I definitely think that that's a good thing.
Running into roadblocks when you're trying to
purchase a firearm, even as a, you know, a safe,
normal citizen, so to speak, I think is a good
thing. It shouldn't be easy to get a firearm.
Speaker 1: I agree. And listen, in New
York City, I'll just say it this way.
I have experienced. You know, it could be
for friends. I have experience the New York
City process for the handgun permit. And it's not
easy, but it is possible. And if you do it right,
then it's a permit that you're able to get.
Speaker 2: Let me ask you just this one related
question, and I'll let you go. I had seen an
idea that I think could appeal to the right wing
as well after they get over the fact that, you
know, it's a change which is difficult for them
to process. It was essentially like an evolving
gun license where for each firearm that you wanted
to own or even just fire it, you had to qualify
on that particular firearm. And therefore, that
license would almost be like a like collecting. It
would tap into that kind of psyche of collecting,
and you could. That's a super interesting idea.
Speaker 1: That's a super. I mean, commercial
commercial pilots have to qualify
on the planes that they fly. I think
that's a super interesting idea. Dev from
Syracuse, great to hear from you. Very,
very interesting. Let's go next to John in
Sharpeville. John in Sharpeville. Welcome to
The David Pakman Show. What's on your mind
today? John in Sharp's bill, I've invited
you to participate. You do need to accept my
invitation. It was going so well today until
we got to John in Charlottesville. All right.
Well, I guess we're not going to hear from him